so this is an area quite an extensive
area of woodland where they've been
tackling a fire since around one o'clock
i'm told it's an area the size of around
five football pitches so quite a large
fire we've got um
teams here from hereford and worcester
uh fire and rescue also west midlands
and shropshire teams as well because
they need these specialist off-road
vehicles to get up to where the fire is
if you have a little look over there you
can see that the scorched earth where
they've managed to sort of get the fire
out on this part they're just dampening
it down at the moment um
so
they say when they arrived here about
one o'clock the fire was raging about to
the height to head height here so so
really quite an extensive scene so um
yeah an area about the size of five
football pitches they've had to evacuate
three homes there's residential
properties just over to the left of
where i'm standing so three homes have
had to be evacuated and the teams say
that whilst it is um contained the wind
is unpredictable so it is still quite an
evolving scene at the moment um so yeah
for the teams here you can see
i mean they've brought us up here you
know they say that we're we're safe to
be where we are but you can see just
beyond there very smoky
and and still a fair bit of work for
them to do now they don't know what
caused this fire at the moment um they
say i mean it could have been so hot the
ground is so dry this it could have been
something like a cigarette butt it could
have been somebody having a barbecue but
they say i mean look this kind of scene
is exactly why uh fire services across
the country are really urging people
just not to do that sort of thing at the
moment around woodland because it sparks
so quickly and there's a really large
fire now being tackled as i say by quite
a large number of fire teams here